it's an optimization workshop as was
pointed out already in the review in the
workshop one of the themes of the
workshop is not a mix of permutation
which is an area that is focused
attention and here we have the expert in
this topic
Sufis draw from MIT who alters a nice
overview and better understanding of
this area I am NOT of course going to be
able to do a full overview so I'm going
to do a biased overview but I just want
to mostly keep it at a very high level I
just want to expose people to a bunch of
results in the area so I apologize
there's no theorem proving that I will
be doing here but I my focus is to
really expose people to the kinds of
results with a bias towards large-scale
non convex optimization and like any
other non convex talk the first slide is
the obligatory slide which is just a
reminder to ourselves before that I'm
not claiming anything grand in here
simple non convex problems like that are
as we all know not so easy classical
example so here of that simple quadratic
with trivial constraints looks very easy
we know that this encode subset-sum
problem so it's a very hard problem and
then you may say ok well let's forget
global optimality let's focus on just
local optimality and even there and make
this escape in the beginning that in
general even testing local optimality
can be hard but that's not going to stop
us but just saying that I am NOT gonna
make very strong claims and though we
will go towards local optimality towards
the end so that was like my escape code
that whatever we talk about non convex
is good to remember that even humble
looking problems including testing local
optimality can be np-hard so yeah
because this something has been a
recurring theme throughout even if you
have even if it was unconstrained if I
replace X was with the squares testing
if X is a local minimum so split then
that's one point that we always ask for
these things where the Hessian is
greater than minus epsilon I we just
kind of want to reach that place but it
doesn't really yeah but being I guess
the focus here being kind of more
machine learning pragmatism style I'm
willing to do some epsilon approximate
things that I accept but I I really like
to bring this example of that even I
start you effort off at a local minimum
in a non-convex problem you won't be
able to tell that you are at a local
minimum so it can happen for trivial
looking problems which are not actually
so trivial but that aside nothing's
gonna stop us from talking about
large-scale stuff so the talk is gone we
mostly focus on optimization I'm not
talking about actually of course I can't
cover cover all the trends and I'm not
gonna focus that much on batch methods
by that I mean full gradient methods so
my bias is more towards stochastic /
incremental gradient approaches for
large-scale settings and I think Steve
right they talk about batch non-convex
approaches in his talk couple of days
ago and I am NOT going to talk about a
super important topic which is
generalization because the place where
this non convex optimization is
extremely hot is in machine learning in
the story of the gap between our
knowledge of optimization in our
knowledge of generalization that's a
severe gap but I'm gonna focus on just
let's say the easy part and I know
there's a bunch of people here in the
audience maybe in the room maybe outside
right now it's Simons who have worked
quite a bit on non convex optimization I
if I'm missing somebody's work I
apologize in advance I try to be
somewhat thorough but it's a fast-moving
area
aunt bee if I'm missing something you
know please let me know okay so with
that let's go on to the kinds of topics
the background is really this motivating
problem from the world of deep neural
networks it's an empirical risk
minimization problem you have n training
samples and can be large millions
billions whatever and you're just trying
to minimize some non convex function and
the cost function is encoded by say a
deep neural network although it could
also include things like spectral
problems eigenvector problems which are
kind of tractable non convex problems or
mixture modeling or matrix and tensor
factorization problems a variety of such
problems you can kind of look at them in
this generic framework and what I'm
going to really focus on principally is
that's why I just abstracting away
what's inside the F I'm using the
machine learning convention of using
theta as or the statistics convention
theta as the variable rather than X
which may be more common in optimization
and that's the problem and we look at
some variants of this empirical risk
minimization problem and just so
background history just quick super
quick you know classically the famous
robbins Munroe paper from 1951 looked at
such types of problems came up with some
asymptotic convergence rates such a
topic has been deeply studied back in
the day so there is ancient work by norm
Shaw on space dilation methods
there's variable metric SGD methods for
that which we are save he has a whole
sequence of works on those and within
say adding some convexity and some
convergence theory within the world of
machine learning there are things like a
degrade which are special cases of
variable metric methods but with a
different kind of analysis and popular
in the neural network areas this atom
method which is another such scale
gradient method and so on and most of
these methods people do have some strong
analysis for convex case and for a long
time for the non convex case
analyzing the stochastic or these
large-scale methods most of the results
that were available were only asymptotic
and it's I don't think that it's because
non asymptotic results were hard to
prove they were not really that hard to
prove it's just that the community
didn't care about them at that time
that's all
and in machine learning inspired by the
attention to iteration complexity coming
from convex optimization because it
gives a strong statement about
computational complexity the focus now
recently shifted into talking about
iteration complexity for these setups
you argue that the reason people like to
talk about iteration complexity machine
learning is because they like to use
optimization error and generalization
error and compare those two numbers is
that the reason why we have that
interest that is one reason because you
can make the translation been doing
stochastic optimization you can make the
translation to generalization error but
I think even outside of that because
people say is in theory CS will started
using convex optimization for solving
some theory C as problems they want
bound computational complexity so it's
important to talk about global iteration
complexity there - there's a nice blog
post by I think Sebastian ruder on it's
a nice entertaining blog post on he
experiments with 20 different gradient
based methods and all these flavors if
you're interested in the numerix is a
nice blog to have a look at okay and
really the focus is you know going
beyond just SGD by calling it going
beyond sounds like something fancy is
gonna happen so it's not it's not going
to be that fancy but hopefully a little
bit and okay this is just some
prehistory so I'll actually skip that
because I just learned from maryam that
the amount of time I have for the speech
here is slightly lesser than the
originally declared time so let's not do
too much history but actually dive into
current times so just to set the stage
there are for most people a lot of the
things will be trivial but it's just
good to set up the stage just in case
somebody is not fully familiar with the
playing field and after that it'll be
simple pretty clear so simple 1d non
convex optimization problem you have an
inflection point local minimum low
global minimum
so getting to global minimum as we
already saw is hard and what we end up
doing of course in higher D this
actually looks non convex this actually
is one of the non convex functions which
I think is globally optimal simple by
doing other clever stuff which I'm not
going to talk about but this is just an
illustration of things with saddle
points of what we are going to settle
with is the key the key separation kind
of between say non convex and convex
when it comes to designing optimization
algorithms is unlike the convex case we
don't have the luxury of necessary and
sufficient first-order conditions let's
say so but at least they are necessary
so we try to say that ok at least we
have to satisfy necessary conditions so
let's see how quickly can your algorithm
satisfy necessary conditions of
optimality so that's really the focus
initially and later on I'll quickly
because I call the trends make a few
remarks about if you want to claim
something more about your stationary
point rather than just stationarity you
want to try to claim approximate
optimality then you have to look at or
at least it's reasonable to look at
second-order conditions for local minima
leti we try to approximately satisfy
those but most of the time I'm just
gonna summarize some work which is
trying to change this local optimality
condition and just as a reminder in the
convex land we have the luxury of
bounding or distance to optimal so we
just call it the optimality gap and we
don't really have such a luxury in the
non convex land so
it's kind of common to measure
approximate stationarity so I just call
it the stationerity gap and that kind of
suggests to you already for those of you
who do optimization that this is a
differentiable problem if you had other
setups like non differentiable or other
all sorts of problems you just replace
that with a corresponding function that
measures stationarity so for instance
you had a non smooth problem and nest of
talks about this in passing in his book
and then the Demian length study that
and the reason I'm saying this
expectation there is remember I'm going
to recess that again and again we are
looking at used the board once to have
used the board once we are looking at
optimizing
this particular empirical risk
minimization problem so--that's and we
use a randomized method so that's why
the gap is in expectation and just for
notational convenience I put a square in
there it annoys some people so if it
annoys you please bear with me some
people like to not use the square
they're slightly easier and the setup in
which we are measuring this progress is
very simple setup we want to count how
many incremental Oracle calls do you
make which means in simpler language how
many individual gradients or maybe
function values in addition if you wish
do you make to satisfy that condition to
epsilon accuracy so that's the playing
field and here is a simple comparison
between stochastic gradient descent and
great versus gradient descent so
stochastic gradient descent runs that
iteration so let's say it said the one
extreme of the spectrum and gradient
descent computes the gradient of the
fall summations I said the other extreme
and we assume this kind of standard
thing that the gradients of these things
don't fluctuate too wildly so they're
Lipschitz smooth so for what SGD does is
at each iteration it invokes it computes
one stochastic gradient of an
incremental gradient and after one by
epsilon square iterations it satisfies
that optimality stationarity condition
for you so the total number of
incremental gradients it has to call is
1 by order 1 by epsilon square the Oh
hides Lipsius constants and diameters
and other such stuff which are usually
very hard to compute so we hide them and
the nice thing is it's independent of n
the number of
samples there I mean training
observations interestingly is such a
result was formally published only in
2013 and for gradient descent for
comparison and this is like really
important this is super basic but really
important because this comparison
underlies the rest of the fancier stuff
I'm gonna speak so at one iteration it
computes a full gradient which amounts
to n incremental gradients so one call
of one step of gradient descent has n
incremental calls and we know that it
takes off one by epsilon iterations to
satisfy the epsilon stationarity so it's
a quick three line exercise in estrus
book and so you take a total of n by
epsilon incremental calls and you can
see this depends strongly on N and the
question at this point is that can we
find something in the middle it's kind
of an obvious thing once you place them
side by side like that and by the theory
of talks the answer to this question
must be yes so answer is there's some
popular methods in convex optimization
which are methods which are called sag s
vrg saga and there's the whole saga of
these methods that I could tell you but
the analysis of these methods goes
around it says hey we are looking at
rather than the full gradient we are
looking at a stochastic gradient
stochastic gradient has some variance
it's a stochastic estimator of a
gradient and the amount of that variance
governs how fast this thing is going to
converge and if we could reduce that
variance you could potentially converge
faster and that underlying idea was
given shape in these papers for the
convex case so mark is not here these
guys they started that show in 2012 and
then it kind of became very popular I
know that Mert read also and Pablo they
looked at deterministic versions also of
the incremental methods and this this is
a gigantic number of
papers on that topic in the convex case
so actually Frances Bach and I had a
tutorial at nips on this topic where
Frances covered a full length story of
the that family of methods for contacts
case in case you're interested
anyhow so these methods they exist for
the convex case and their analysis of
variance reduction that why they give
better estimators relies heavily on
convexity they do get big due probably
faster than SGD but the analysis relies
a lot of convexity and we were wondering
if you can get around that reliance on
convexity and yet benefit from the idea
of variance reduction if the answer is
actually yes they these methods do work
but requires a slightly different
analysis and one thing that so my
students Shashank at CMU he worked on
this a lot with me over the years and he
told me that when I talk about this one
thing I should mention here is it looks
like that the analysis at least our
analysis for the non convex version of
these variance to do stochastic methods
it mimics a kind of nester of estimate
sequence idea even though this is in the
non convex case so that's an interesting
analysis in case you're interested in so
the idea works and let me show you what
it does quick reminder of what the
actual algorithm is so and I'm just
picking one this is a bunch of such
methods out there this one is very
simple to understand and explain so let
me mention that so what this method SVR
G does it runs instead of running
stochastic gradient which would be
essentially the method you run it like
that oh there's a typo here with s plus
one sorry
so instead of running stochastic
gradient method with just a stochastic
gradient it runs a double loop in an
outer loop it computes a full gradient
sounds nasty and an inner loop it
instead of using just the stochastic
grade
at one point it uses information from
the full gradient to reduce the variance
of the inner stochastic gradient and
then just uses this and it so and it
proceeds in loops too so the outer loop
goes through s times keep some kind of
snapshot around and then you do the
inner loop which is essentially
stochastic gradient but with a different
stochastic gradient which is biased like
this I mean shifted like this it's an
unbiased estimator so it is unbiased
because of that that is an expectation
will give a stochastic gradient and this
an expectation is zero see this this is
a snapshot that we kept outside so
actually I'm just showing it in here for
illustration you just compute this stuff
once outside the loop try not to
implement it by computing it every time
inside the loop so this is computed
that's why once every epoch in the
outside and the whole game is these are
the key quantities how many outer a
parks how many inner stochastic steps
and how what's the step size so these
three quantities govern the total
complexity and what is the total
complexity we are after the total number
of incremental Oracle calls so how many
incremental small gradients do we need
to compute so each time you touch the
outer loop that's like n in M steps in
the inner loop is little m so if you
carefully trade this off the total
number of incremental calls in with an
amortized analysis can be reduced to do
better than batch gradient descent
what it really does is if you take
larger step sizes then you end up having
to run a smaller inner loop and if you
run a smaller inner loop the method
looks more and more like batch gradient
descent because in some sense the batch
method is using a more accurate gradient
if your gradient is more accurate you
can use larger step sizes roughly
speaking and a few smaller step sizes
converges may slow down and it
translates into doing more work in the
inner loop and carefully trading these
off this theory kind of tells how to do
these trade-offs optimally you end up
with a good choice of how many inner
loops how many outer loops what step
size is to come up with an overall lower
complexity so here is the summary of the
results about the complexity so SGD
takes one by epsilon square to get an
epsilon stationary point gradient
descent takes n by epsilon this s vrg
saga etc they give us a huge I'm just
kidding
saving from n to n to the 2 by 3 and yam
is it's it's some kind of saving right
you can make n a big number and say that
we saved a lot a lot of work went into
that but a very interesting thing that's
about to write a very interesting thing
is we don't know if you can improve on
that n to the 2 by 3 so we have this
result that this is the speed-up you get
some other people who also worked on
this they also got a similar speed up
from n to n to the 2 by 3 and it's an
open problem to decide is this the best
you can do by doing variance reduction
so every time we try to speed stuff up
we hit this n to the 2 by 3 barrier I
don't know why that's happening I mean
the analysis kind of tells that ok
juggle these quantities you optimize
something this is what comes out but is
this the best possible I don't know
I would yeah I don't know I don't want
to take bets in any direction so it
could be the best possible for the svr
Jian saga
style of optimization methods you could
cook up some other version of stochastic
method which could be better than this I
don't know if this is a barrier for the
whole class of gradient based
optimization methods or it's just a
barrier for this particular double loop
style of methods anyhow that's an
interesting theoretical question that's
still open so that that's one so the
other thing I want you to mention to you
which actually mark is an expert on the
collection of Awesome conditions in
optimization that allow us to globally
optimize non convex functions so these
are not convex but they are morally
convex and the class of models under
which things are convex that's a nice
class to study one of those classes is
this famous boy I see which class of
functions which simplified similarly a
simpler version was studied by polio in
63 these are functions which we call
gradient dominated functions so if you
have a function G this is a and in any
differentiable function whose distance
to its optimal so this is the global
Optima so that we already assumed a
powerful thing about G G is distance to
its global optimum or to a global Optima
Moffitt's in terms of its gradients so
if this happens then we are then we can
do many things and this condition
happens to be actually more general than
a bunch of other restricted strong
convexity weak strong convexity and
whatnot convexity conditions that arise
I think if you are more interested in
figuring out more about this class you
know ask mark is sitting back there and
he knows this class very well but the
cool thing about this class is that of
course strongly convex functions imply
this one of the things I want to mention
right now is problems like principal
components analysis like trying to find
the largest eigen
let's have a PSD matrix that problem is
a simple non-convex problem which we
know from eigenvalue business that it's
globally solvable that particular
problem ends up satisfying of polyak
wire see with style inequality not it's
with the double star so there are some
caveats to that it satisfies it in a
non-euclidean sense not in a Euclidean
space it satisfies it on a manifold
sense but point is it satisfies that
type of inequality which explains in
indirectly or directly that if I were to
now throw a gradient based method at an
eigenvector problem poof I would expect
fast convergence to global Optima so
that's a nice geometric property so
there's a bunch of other variations of
this that have been studied including
two non differentiable functions mark
has done that with students and this is
member of a more general class of these
called a away a see which class of the
stuff that people have studied in
differential geometry or this also goes
under the name of soo bahk of noise
model in statistics etc etcetera these
are basically conditions that people say
around an optimum how fast my function
grows and if you have some control on
how fast your function grows around an
optimum you can feed that back into to
design optimization methods anyhow but
say cus has a new textbook which talks
about tens of such growth conditions on
functions that if your functions satisfy
those growth conditions even sometimes
without having access to convexity you
can solve them optimize them to global
optimality so here is a quick summary if
you had this awesome condition then even
for non convex functions we can get
results too for stochastic optimization
problems to global optimality so you get
actually linear rate of convergence now
you have log 1 by epsilon tiles stuff
and annoyingly maybe it's just our
analysis once again that n to the 2 by 3
stuff comes up so we couldn't get rid of
that
so this is this is an interesting
example because this is non convex and
you get global optimality so that's a
class that I think it's good to be aware
of okay so here is a toy example a
couple of empirical results I've thrown
in so we just try to use this non convex
SVR G method to fit a neural network
just very simple neural network to
layers so the y-axis talks about
training loss the x-axis is the number
of passes through the data so it's
that's why number of gradients divided
by N and is the sample size right so
this is how many full passes you do so
if you multiply that with n you know
that this the number of IFO calls and
the various reduce method is a better
optimization method than SGD so the
theory suggested that experiment on a
small problem also validates that and in
fact the theorem was more about
stationarity and you do see as suggested
by the theory the method does decrease
stationarity get faster a weird think
that this is a small neural network so
we also had this luxury which doesn't
always happen that in fact even for test
error the faster method did a better job
but not gonna talk about test error that
much because of this the question is
does this kind of trend continue to hold
if I were to try to optimize a deep
neural network using these faster
methods and the answer to that is
neither yes nor no as usual it it
depends it depends who on who's
implementing it in whose experimenting
with it it takes a lot of effort to get
some answers out there but generically
yes if you're not clever about it it's
very easy to screw up with better
optimization methods so Ben knows that
very well that if you are better at
optimization it's pretty easy to screw
up performance on deep networks
so this one is claiming to be better at
optimization so to make it compete on a
deep neural network you have to work
harder that's only for the tester for
optimization of course it does a better
job so okay so something worth noting
now as I cover more trends the world of
non smooth non convex optimization
begins to open some surprises and in
convex land what happens is because of a
very complete sub differential calculus
of non smooth stuff many things that you
can do with smooth convex optimization
at least in principle a large number of
those algorithms and analysis you can
carry over into the non smooth setting
if you manage to encapsulate your non
smoothness nicely and somehow in the non
convex land even if the non smooth part
of your minimization problem is a convex
function like elver norm for sparsity or
an indicator function to enforce a
constraint set we run into some
surprises and what happens you look at
this type of settings so non convex
composite objective problem most
harmless-looking kind of problem almost
so the differentiable part so the non
convex part we assume it to be
differentiable and the non
differentiable part we assume it to be
convex so the simplest kind of non
smoothness and if you were to run this
vanilla method like proximal stochastic
gradient descent so if things were
convex you could run this so what
proximal stochastic gradient descent is
doing is it takes the stochastic
iteration and hits it with essentially
projection like operator which handles
the non smooth part it's like soft
thresholding or just orthogonal
projection if you have if this function
is the indicator of a constraint set you
can apply that and if if the problem is
convex this also works you can easily
prove it procs operators are non
expensive etcetera etcetera
so for procs SGD convergence is not
known for non-convex problems it's kind
of unsettling that such a basic method
so this is one of the open second open
problems maybe more interesting than my
end to the 2x3 problems is this obvious
method that you would just program out
of the box we don't know if it converges
let alone rate so there is a partial
progress by gamelon and some in which
uses the following idea that for
stochastic case we don't know it
converges so let's gradually make the
method non stochastic by using ever
larger mini-batches
so make it less and less stochastic and
then you can prove a convergence there's
a double loop plus projection plus sub
gradient method by Domecq davison
grimmer which actually has a projection
and sub gradient and they do have some
rates but the method is more complex
than just the vanilla iteration so
understanding whether this works or
coming up with a counter example that it
doesn't work would be really good to
know so that's non convex surprise
are there any experiments that suggest
this good work so the like the obvious
experiments that you run it seems to
work but I don't know I'm guessing that
one should be able to make it work but
you may need one or two small technical
assumptions on variance and the
intuition for that is actually here that
if instead of vanilla stochastic
gradient you were to use stochastic
gradients with lesser variance then we
can actually show that the iteration
converges again at that crazy end to the
two by three by Epsilon rate and now
I've seen it in three or four places
that's why I thought that okay either
that's the limit of our analysis or
maybe this is what these methods can do
at best but there is some care needed in
there so there's not like out of the box
you can do variance reduction and it
works a weird thing happens if you just
apply variance reduction out of the box
you can prove convergence and you can
prove convergence at the rate and by
epsilon oops
stochastic method with the same
complexity as the deterministic method
we gained nothing so you have to be a
little more careful to get speed up even
with variance reduction so it could be
that without variance reduction this is
much trickier the way you implement the
algorithm yeah
and I'll already okay because you asked
that already give away the answer and
that's another open problem if you use a
sufficiently large mini-batch in
addition to reducing the variance then
you can get it however here the
mini-batch has to be just sufficiently
large it doesn't have to grow so it's
the mini-batch has to be of size sub
linear in n but it has a non it's non
constant so it depends on n the number
of training data points and if you can
make a method converge by just using a
constant size mini batch
I think because in all my
implementations and all our experiments
constant size mini-batch seems to work
so I believe it will work here too
but I don't know no so fortunately not
yeah okay so let me maybe whatever this
is like some experimental results on
applying this to non negative pca type
problem so that's just let me move ahead
to just show you that okay this does
work better in practice also i just
mentioned here because it's kind of
analyzing stochastic algorithms for
large-scale pca problems is a has been
popular in past couple of years in the
machine learning community this bunch of
people listed here and there's more
papers on that topic but anyhow let's
move ahead i'll just mention one of my
favorite non convex structures under
which you can make interesting claims is
if you are looking at this empirical
risk minimization problems but the
parameters that you're optimizing rather
than come from a Euclidean space they
come from a non linear surface like a
manifold the same kind of ideas go
through so I'll give you an advanced
moral of the story because I have to
accelerate is that this various reduce
business wherever you have you use
gradient methods various reduce methods
wherever you have previously managed to
use gradient methods whether it is for
many folds or Euclidean optimization
various reduce methods almost always
carry over speaking so so some of the
problems that have this flavor is
problems I can vector style problems
problems with orthogonality constraints
low ranked matrices PSD matrices and so
on and I'll give you a toy example were
just cite here what we did so we looked
at last year to solve that problem and
there's a bunch of previous work again
classically all the work on optimization
with the manifold structure was all
asymptotic and our people kind of starts
out non asymptote
take results which actually is not just
as people didn't care about it
previously but to write known asymptotic
results for optimization over curved
spaces we had to also develop some new
mathematical machinery but that's a
topic for another talk and but this is
just to tell you that this idea of
finite sum minimization with stochastic
methods holds more generally beyond
Euclidean spaces also and give you an
example of one of my favorite problems
which takes the shape as motivation is
textbook example of Gaussian mixture
models so if you're trying to fit a
mixture model of capital K number of
gaussians to iid samples so the
likelihood is just this right and the
numerical challenge of maximizing this
problem so you can take a logarithm and
write it as a sum so it'll start looking
like that problem so the numerical
challenge of solving that problem is
satisfying the positive definiteness
constraint on the covariance matrices
and one way to handle it successfully
throughout which everybody probably here
has heard of is the e/m algorithm which
allows you to get very easily to satisfy
closed form PhD constraint you can make
the problem an unconstrained it's
already non convex you can make it known
you can continue remaining non convex by
replacing the PSD constraint with
Achille sk decomposition so your
constraint becomes ll transpose now it's
unconstrained in L you can do that it's
not numerically I don't think it's ever
really a good idea but some people may
disagree with me on that and we thought
that okay this is a PSD constraint
positive definite matrices form some
kind of manifold so you can just try to
apply our manifold machinery to solve
maximize this costume likelihood and it
turns out with some care you can do that
and we actually have a full solver
available on github which implements a
manifold version of l-bfgs with some
other fairly careful linear algebra in
there so small smallish dimension 35
hundred thousand points so am kind of
runs does its thing and this is really
using standard popular well-established
implementations of VM and if you solve
it rather than classical iam you solve
it as an optimization problem then you
actually end up greatly speeding things
up and moreover it turns out to operate
more robustly and reliably quite
interestingly so to me the reason I'm
showing you this example as an
optimization person I was always annoyed
whenever I read claims like you can't be
TM I mean for no optimization method one
can make such a claim you know you can
always know this M is just one of the
other optimization methods so it just
happens to have a beautiful format but
you can also beat it and the nice thing
about thinking of it as an optimization
problem using this finite sum machinery
is things like stochastic parallel
distributed etcetera all these followers
buy products once you think in the
optimization style so you can do develop
a theory of stochastic manifold
optimization and you see the usual kind
of beard pictures they're stochastic
methods really kick-ass and that's what
happens here and yeah so it actually
ends it for larger and larger data set
these effects are more and more
pronounced and it requires a little bit
of work to carry over stochastic
analysis to manifolds but one can do it
and so the summary of the stuff so far
and because I think
to where I wanna be so the summary of
stuff so far I just gave you a
high-level idea of looking at this
large-scale non convex optimization
problems classically people continue to
use SGD and in then if you really want
to solve the optimization problem
instead of SGD you can use methods like
saga or sv RG or other methods which
reduce the variance and provably and
also empirically converge faster not
necessarily on the generalization error
that's a topic of course for another day
and there are some open problems in
there which I raised I'd love to know
answers to those open problems if
anybody's has any ideas please catch me
and this ideas go across to manifolds
also so that was summary so far and I
kind of want to gradually now wrap up by
showing you some perspectives about the
other trends that I didn't talk about I
only have finite time like all of you so
current trends the thing that been
complained about a little bit in the
beginnings like if you want to escape
you don't want to be just stationary you
want to kind of have some confidence
that you are approximately satisfying
second-order criticality how much more
additional effort do you need to
basically get out of saddle points and
that's a current popular subtopic where
we say ok we want to get epsilon
stationarity and we want to be ideally
for it to be a local minimum this has to
be strictly positive definite if it's
just in the if it's just semi definite
then you're at a stationary point and
you need higher-order knowledge to judge
but we kind of tolerate this you know I
think I agree with you one of the
reasons we told it is maybe because it's
easy to prove a theorem but maybe
there's a better reason also numerically
there's hardly there's not much more
that we can do other than mix this with
the idea that if you're stationary point
is not degenerate
so none of the eigenvalues of the
Hessian is truly zero then a gradient
based method with overwhelming
probability is not gonna remain sitting
at a stationary point so maybe that kind
of hand wavy motivation one can use to
tolerate this even though this does not
exclude zero eigenvalues so yeah so
there's a bunch of work on escaping
those so SGD reaches approximate
stationarity doesn't ensure second-order
criticality people have used add noise
to SGD and make this assumption about
strict saddle point so I call it
assumption on the structure of the
hessian and show that okay with some
work you can ensure second-order
criticality but then you start your
method the running time starts depending
obscenely also known as exponentially on
dimension and there's other ideas which
basically cleverly alternate between
first-order and second-order approaches
that okay if you really want to do
second-order stationarity then better do
something second-order now and then at
least and ideally okay so let's so
ideally what you'd want is to nicely
blend a first-order approach with a
second-order approach so this is the
number of iteration this is the type
plot this is not real that second-order
method with do a great job nailing the
optimization objective function value
first-order method just get stuck at a
saddle point and what you want is to
kind of benefit from second-order and
first order speed that you see here that
ideally you want something that goes as
fast as and as low or does as good a job
as second-order but faster so this is
the desired plot okay this is not what
any method is achieving here it's a kind
of made-up lot and so there's a bunch of
work on that I think on tomorrow
probably Z&L and so he's gonna talk
about some some work related I guess to
doing finite sum plus escaping
saddle-point if I'm right and there's a
related there's bunch of related work on
that but since I'm out of time I'm not
going to make a long commentary but it
is here listed about various different
assumptions on Hessians on smoothness
and whatnot for which people are trying
to [ __ ] up method which probably escape
saddle points but the most important
thing in cooking of these methods that
provably escape saddle points is to
never really explicitly construct the
hessian so that's really the thing
you're after and somewhere in there a
stochastic Lance or iteration also pops
up because you need a direction of
descent so you need something some
knowledge about the eigenvectors of your
hessian and the art is plus with the
theory balancing those things correctly
so that you don't need to do too much of
the hessian level stuff to retain
overall fast convergence so i don't have
time to go into that so let me skip that
we have some plots on actual data where
you can do that on deep autoencoder so
this is actually fairly difficult deep
problems what one can do reasonable good
job anyhow one yeah so I because we're
out of time so unfortunately you can see
the million other things that I wanted
to tell you about but couldn't tell you
about the this too many other
interesting things in the world of non
convex optimization but I will close by
talking about the things which are of
actual immediate theoretical interest
that I want to bring to this audience's
attention and I think when told me to
stop so I guess I have to stop
Hey
[Applause]
so conceptually of course as you make
your mini batch larger and larger you
averaged more and more gradients so the
variance reduces there is a way but
think of trying to implement that it's a
little hard to do that in an
implementation so one could do that in
the end I think what we're after is how
many so like a fair way to talk about
such methods when you compare them is
how many total number of calls to the
incremental Oracle did you have to make
if you use a mini batch of size billion
then you made billion more calls
so however there's a slight caveat to
that some people they talk about mini
batches in the context of parallel so
that the cost of extra Oracle's is
reduced but to really make a
theoretically strong statement I think
if you count the full complexity merely
increasing the bat size most likely is
not going to do the job
so these ones are large like academic
large in the sense that they fit in my
they fit in a big computers memory so it
could be just ten million or something
but one can start taking these things to
distributed machines so they're large
could easily mean ten billion so it
could mean anything
so really depends on how big your
computer is there was the slide that I
didn't talk about is the second last
slide about the sequence of acceleration
methods non-convex and momentum methods
in non convex and quasi Newton methods
in non convex I didn't talk about any of
that it fits in in the same way as for
convex that you're it improves your
dependence on the geometric constants
like Lipschitz constants etcetera that I
hit in the Big O very conveniently so
yeah that's that is another interesting
topic but yeah that's actually a very
nice question and so for the for merely
this particular problem that I showed
for the unconstrained problem there's
essentially no difference but a very
weird thing happens that I didn't get a
chance to talk about when we are doing
constrained optimization so you can also
apply this saga SVR G etcetera idea to
constrained optimization with Frank wolf
and there there seems to be a gap
between the complexity of saga versus
complexity of SVR G which I don't
understand so they they have some
foundational difference maybe Mark has
some insight
on what foundational differences they
may have in this particular case there
was essentially no difference okay
that's thanks to breathe again next
otter